alors si ce divorce est aussi
qu'augmenter c'est parce qu'il s'agit
d'une situation inédite
on l'a entendu c'est aussi parce que le
couple présidentiel a mêlé le public et
le privé
nicolas sarkozy a toujours affiché le
rôle de premier plan joué par cécilia
dans sa vie personnelle et politique
jusqu'à ces derniers mois récit signé
michael darmon jean marc notebook
elle ne voulait pas venir à la concorde
d'ailleurs elle reste en arrière et
michèle alliot-marie unis leurs mains 6
mai 2007 jour de victoire pour nicolas
sarkozy en coulisses une journée
difficile pour son couple
plus tard on apprendra même que la
future première dame n'a pas voté et oui
il est bien loin le temps si c'est bien
sarkozy faisait visiter aux caméras ses
appartements privés du ministère de
l'intérieur
mais sarkozy se voit comme les kennedy
il famille politique moderne
ils mettent leur bonheur sincère au
service d'un projet présidentiel
vie privée vie publique les sarkozy
efface la frontière sous l'oeil des
médias lorsque son mari prend la tête de
l'ump
cécilia sarkozy devient chef de cabinet
du parti
entre les deux les relations se tendent
et en pleine campagne pour le référendum
de 2005 elle craque
voici la dernière réunion de l'ump à
laquelle assistent cécilia sarkozy
la tension est presque palpable en
bouleau table se trouve le publicitaire
richard attias avec lequel elle passera
plusieurs mois à new york
la crise conjugale de nicolas sarkozy
défraie la chronique
il fait face à la télévision lors la
vérité elle est très simple comme des
millions de familles la mienne a connu
des difficultés ces difficultés nous
sommes en train de les surmonter
est ce que je dois en dire plus je ne
pense pas cécilia comme beaucoup pour
moi chacun le sait
je crois que la réciproque est également
vraie la séparation dure presque un an
et et 2006 il se retrouvait le ministre
de l'intérieur affiche la réconciliation
lors d'un voyage en guyane
on parle désormais de peopolisation de
la vie politique
mais nicolas sarkozy affirme pourtant
qu'il ne veut plus exposer sa vie
familiale
c'est justement instruit de l'expérience
que j'ai décidé plus jamais
durant toute la campagne présidentielle
cécilia sarkozy reste en retrait et son
absence est omniprésente
mais elle s'interroge entre l'ombre et
la lumière quelle vie choisir le 16 mai
2007 dans la cour de l'elysée elle
rayonne à la tête de sa famille
recomposée et donne le ton d'une ère
nouvelle à l'elysée
comme m
elle ma delun zilina le couple
présidentiel donne alors l'apparence
d'une relation apaisée
sacha tard
oui
c'est bien trop
mais si les gestes amoureux sont bien là
le coeur n'y est pas pour cécilia
sarkozy commence pour elle une vie entre
convenance et protocoles pour sa
première apparition g8 elle casse les
codes du club des dirigeants de la
planète en séchant la photo des femmes
de chefs d'état tout le monde
s'interroge sur l'idée qu'elle se fait
de son rôle elle veut prendre son temps
à protéger sa famille je trouve que
c'est très bien la façon montagnes fait
nicolas sarkozy reconnaît les affres de
son épouse
et pour son premier 14 juillet il lui
adresse un message public dirhams à
cécilia et à judith mais elles sont très
belles toutes les deux sur le perron de
l'elysée quelques jours plus tard
cécilia sarkozy devient une héroïne
nationale en bulgarie elle ramène dans
leur patrie les infirmières prisonnière
en libye depuis huit ans émissaire
personnel du président elle s'est
beaucoup impliqué dans cette affaire
m
désormais l'agenda international masque
ou accompagnent les crises en vacances
aux états unis elles prétextent une
angine de dernière minute pour se
décommander au pique nique offert par la
famille bush
cécilia sarkozy ne veux plus de cette
vie dans le monde politique aux obsèques
de jacques martin le père de ses deux
filles sa décision est prise et elle
annule dans la foulée sa présence à new
york
elle n'assistera pas au premier discours
de son mari à la tribune de l'onu
alors que nicolas sarkozy se rend seul
en bulgarie auprès des infirmières les
rumeurs de séparation se font de plus en
plus précises signe des temps l'elysée
vient d'officialiser pour la première
fois dans l'histoire de la république
une rupture conjugale au sommet de
l'état
oui dans la pratique